the question is is it too late to start
YouTube right now and the answer is no
in fact if you really see it right now
there is major opportunity to start and
grow a YouTube channel and even reach
your first 100 subscribers and so in
this video I'm gonna be sharing five
quick tips we're gonna do a rapid-fire
session and these are some
unconventional tips that I haven't
really shared anywhere before that will
maybe have you think a little bit
different about growing your YouTube
channel right now if you're new I am
Sean Connell and the co author of the
best-selling book YouTube secrets and
this is coffee with Cannell we're in the
beginning of the show I deliver some
fast-paced value so you can grow on
YouTube grow your business make a
greater impact and then the second part
of the show I'm gonna be bringing on
guests and doing some deep dive QA so if
you're fired up to be watching this
either live or on the replay hit that
like button and let's dive into it how
do you get your first 100 subscribers
number one recognize the season we're
living in recognize the season we're
living in I told you it's a little bit
different than maybe what you would
expect me to say you might say have
better thumbnails have better titles and
man there's plenty of that information
out there but my question is are you
really perceiving the opportunity that
is existing right now look we don't talk
about here at think media and think
marketing about how to profit from a
pandemic we're not trying to be
opportunistic but what we are talking
about is how to profit during a pandemic
and how to maximize impact during this
time and if you haven't recognized the
season we're living in come on content
consumption is through the roof it's at
historic levels YouTube has had to
reduce the quality I don't know if
you've noticed this sometimes when
you're watching it you're like why does
it look so bad because they're even
streaming at lower bandwidth because so
many people are watching content yah-hoo
finest finance told us that viewers
consumption are up by 64% Nielsen is
saying that content consumption overall
is up by 60% and the world is full of
problems right now right maybe that's
your spouse and you have problem
all around you I'm joking and and look
as an entrepreneur as a YouTube creator
as an influencer you're called to solve
problems people are trying to figure out
how to work out from home save money
make money cook from home everything has
been disrupted and there's never been a
better time to pivot your plan but my
question is are you really recognizing
the season that we're living in I read
this proverb in chapter 10 verse 5 and
it says know the importance of the
season you're in and you will be a wise
son but what a waste when an incompetent
son sleeps through the day of
opportunity are you awake right now or
are you sleeping are you like yeah you
know we're locked down I'm gonna ride
this thing out I'm gonna see what
happens here or are you hustling and
really making the most of this
opportunity if you want to get a hundred
subscribers you got to be leaning in
right now people are consuming like
crazy you got to be creating you got to
be posting you got to be thinking about
number two skill up skill up so if you
want to get a hundred subscribers you
got to skill up YouTube
I believe is one of the greatest
personal development processes that
anybody could ever go through come on
you have to learn to deal with haters
and dislikes and the mental toll that
takes on you negative comments
criticizing you in a personal way that
gets under your skin think about it all
day long you got to learn how to film
with your phone or a camera you got to
learn how to edit you got to learn how
to be on camera you got to learn how to
structure a talk or a teaching you gotta
learn how to be funny you got to learn
how to communicate you got to learn how
to tell a story you got to learn design
you gotta learn thumbnails there's a lot
of freaking skills to learn you want to
get your first 100 subscribers you got
to commit to skilling up and if you
recognize the season we're living in
then there's really never been a better
time to skill up you know there's this
huge debate in culture right now during
this lockdown of like no it's okay we're
under a lot of stress rendered a lot of
pressure you don't have to learn Spanish
right now you can just chill out because
we're in a lot of emotional pressure I
agree you can do whatever you want and
then some people are like no if you
don't learn another skill during
the lockdown then you're you weren't you
didn't have opportunity you were just
lazy I'm not even saying either those
things I'm saying what's your dream
what's your ambition you clearly want to
get a hundred script subscribers or a
hundred thousand you want to start a
YouTube channel you want to grow a
YouTube channel and so if that's the
case then your actions should match your
ambitions you know there's no judgment
do whatever the Frick you want play
Final Fantasy all day sleep in eat Ben &
Jerry's chill out if you got time off of
work maybe you're on unemployment you're
like I'm just gonna take this time to
rest amazing
you know you boo like do Heffer if you
want to do but if you got an ambition to
actually grow something significant
don't validate and make excuses and just
put your head in the sand and think oh
whatever you got a skill up you want to
get a hundred subscribers or more then
you got to skill up which brings me to
tip number three and that's create more
than you consume after your recognizing
the season that we're living in you're
skilling up and thank you for being
subscribed here on think media or if
you're on Facebook for liking the page
and for being a part of our community
just here at think media because
obviously we're devoted to helping you
scale up our mission is to help 10,000
people create a full-time living doing
what they love while making a difference
in the world with YouTube and online
video and that's what it's all about
we're gonna help you learn those skills
and you gotta be studying and I think
you can use whatever time you have right
now whether you're working from home or
whether you got all the time in the
world to not just be you know watching
Tiger King for the second time or
killing Eve season can't find season
three I just finished season two with
Sonya I'm trying to find season three
it's not on Hulu you know doing whatever
but like are you investing in content
that will level you up skill you up but
here's a challenge are you creating more
than you're consuming you want to get a
hundred subscribers it's not you're not
gonna get it from studying you only will
get it from posting videos Wow Sean what
an insight the key to success on YouTube
is posting videos on YouTube thank you
so much hit the like button I appreciate
you touch the like button gently right
and so you gotta create more than you
consume I want to challenge you during
lockdown or whenever post videos skill
up and then post skill up and then post
skill up and then post and I actually
want to make a very special announcement
we are doing a really exciting event
coming up soon that is going to help you
skill up and it's actually called the
YouTube influence challenge am i sharing
it on screen I don't know if I am yes I
am
and YouTube influence it's a seven day
challenge it's starting soon you can
actually join the challenge at Tube
influence calm and for seven days we're
going to be breaking down a bunch of
ways that you can skill up right now as
though there's a link to this in the
description below but let's keep this
thing fired up and go in you got to
create more than you consume right now
especially if you want to get to 100
subscribers number four audit your
circle and connect with the strong
community right now you want to get to
100 subscribers I learned this I came
from a small town man I'm a college
dropout grew up on a farm an hour north
of Seattle Washington and Arlington
Washington
I had goats I had a horse that I never
asked for it was a discount horse bit me
all the time he's awful just had a long
conversation with my mom about this I
was like I'm forever traumatized we got
a baby on the way 20 weeks John Bradley
Cannell coming soon and it's like Sony
was like I would love to raise our child
with horses and I was like I wouldn't
yeah I've been traumatized my go horses
are great but when they bite you and
knock you off of the horse under the
crabapple tree
that'll like change outlook you know I
got a little childhood trauma maybe
after some counseling Sean Bradley will
be able to you know experience a little
bit anyways completely off track what -
saying cut at your circle and connect
with the strong community I grew up in a
small town and I grew up and realized
this that honestly sometimes your small
town can make you small minded sometimes
your small business can make you small
minded sometimes your small youtube
channel can make you small minded and
what I mean is it's not a judgmental
thing it's just the level of thinking
that if you if you're shooting for a
hundred subscribers you got to get
around people who think big dream big
are positive or optimistic
I'm not saying separate even from
anybody I'm saying odd at your circle
and ask yourself are you around people
that are leveling you up
are you in you know a community Bible
says iron sharpens iron are you around
iron right like are you around people
that are challenging you not necessarily
making you feel comfortable not just
validating all your choices but actually
challenging you I don't want to be
sharpened by iron I mean like this is so
nice like and a lot of us want to be
comfortable when you get with a strong
community that's doing big things
dreaming bigger then all of a sudden you
begin to see things that are more
possible than ever before you know I met
Benji Travis in our small town
Marysville Washington grew up and 2010
is when we met it was so crazy because
he and I have become great friends
co-author of the book YouTube secrets
who run the channel video influencers
together and sometimes you find someone
that's like on that same level that this
thinks entirely different you talk about
business talk about YouTube talk about
social media talk about leveling up our
health keep each other accountable
strong community now I know maybe you
don't have that and and maybe you feel
even isolated or like you're lonely hey
I want to invite you into our community
oh it's one of the reasons why we're
doing this challenge is we it's in a
private Facebook group and it's seven
days long and it's a chance to connect
with other Purpose Driven content
creators and entrepreneurs so you can
actually get around people thinking
about you know things at a different
level you want to get 100 subscribers
you know there is statistics that tell
us you are an average of the five people
you spend the most time with and you
know people say that in personal
development all the time but it's just
totally true that like if you are around
five Alcoholics guess what you're
probably gonna be the six if you're
around five broke people guess what
you'll probably be the six if you're
around five obese people you'll probably
be the six Forbes did a study and
statistically they showed that you have
higher
percentage chance if you're around
people that have just got a bunch of
divorces this is no again I'm not
setting judgment here this is just facts
that we are affected by the people we're
around so if you want to have more
momentum in business on your YouTube
channel in your life get around people
that are getting the results you want
in fact when I got around Benji he
started running all the time guess what
I run all the time
now I'm friends with one of my mentors
and good friend chalene johnson who's in
all these fitness dvds and stuff and
when we lived in Irvine started getting
around first her content her podcast her
course her videos her books and then I
started shooting video for her and then
we became friends and start doing some
work and I work with her company a
little bit and now we collaborate on
some stuff but here's what happened is
it it rubbed off on me their their way
of thinking their way of eating their
way of living look you do it everyone in
every area of your life we're talking
about getting a hundred subscribers on
YouTube if you're around a bunch of
people that all have ten thousand
subscribers on in YouTube 55,000
subscribers on YouTube and a bunch of
people that got a silver played by him
it's inevitable that you'll be the sixth
right because success leaves clues and
it rubs off on you and people affect us
more than we think man
they really do if you're constantly
consuming a negative news be just
negative toxic environments of whoever
friends or business environment or
whatever's around you I don't know
anybody who actually stays optimistic
and positive and thrives in a toxic
environment you don't take a plant put
it in the dark surround it by poison and
toxicity and say you're gonna thrive to
just be lush fruitful green leaves of
course the environment affects the life
and the health of that plant and we're
the same so all I want to say is out at
your circle and get around a strong
community smash like if you're getting
value out of this and number five smart
strategy you want to get to 100
subscribers just do these tips and just
keep learning and scaling up and and
connect to a community and you'll be
good and then of course get a smart
strategy now this is coffee with channel
we got to do Q&A but again I want to
invite you
we're gonna be going deep seven days in
a private Facebook group the YouTube
influence challenge
I am so flippin excited for this thing
it's coming up learn how to start and
grow a high impact in high profit
YouTube channel and if you go to tube
influence com
you can register it's entirely free and
listen for the first time ever we're
actually gonna be breaking down our
seven step youtube strategy you can see
it right here on the screen and we've
only previously shared this in our
program video ranking Academy we're
gonna be sharing it publicly and seven
day free challenge no strings attached
this is your YouTube stimulus program
not just to get around some people with
proven results my think myself and the
think media team if you're an influencer
that means if you're an author speaker
coach online marketer and you want to
grow your influence you got to be at
this thing if you're an entrepreneur
small business owner you gotta be at
this thing and if you're a creator
whether you want to know how to start
YouTube right or whether you want to
even get more momentum on YouTube look
this seven step system will help you get
to a hundred subscribers and it'll help
you get to a hundred thousand and it'll
help you get to a million at every stage
along the way this is what we do we just
keep going through this process again
this has only been reserved for our
students previously but it's a crazy
time in the world so we got together
with the think media team and were like
yo let's get crazy let's do like a crazy
online event if you've never been a part
of a challenge every single day we're
gonna go live and train every single day
we're gonna do Q&A in the private
Facebook group and every day we're
giving cameras away and gear away and
whatnot it's gonna be super fun
and we got a bunch of sponsors Canon
Blue Microphones diety Sherrow Joby vid
IQ giving away tons of cool stuff again
you could register tube influencer calm
and it's going to be absolutely amazing
so anyways I definitely get registered
for the YouTube influencer challenge
number one recognize the season we're
living in you don't want a disgraceful
son an incompetent son like old language
of the Bible but like right sleeps
through the day of opportunity
don't be asleep right now you gotta wake
up man you got to wake up there's a lot
of bad happening in the world right now
but what you choose to do with your time
right now can change your whole life and
future and business and brand number two
skill up we're gonna be teaching you
some skills and of course that's what
this episode is all about as I bring
some people on for Q&A I'm gonna drop
the link right now and if you want to
come on with coffee with Cannell maybe
Elena's gonna drop that as well and so
I'll drop that click that hope you have
good audio you've got good you know
video and a good connection and create
more than you consume that's a big
challenge right now I'm not saying don't
consume I'm saying consume smart I'm
saying rest and relax
come on Final Fantasy 7 14 hours into
that thing Shawn when do you have time
do you got to take time off bro of
course you got time I'm not worried
about what you're doing with your time
how much are you working when you're
actually working
don't call scrolling on Instagram
working and don't call just repeating
the same old information over and over
again and refusing and procrastinating
from shooting your videos press re chord
and so be creating more than you consume
that's what this challenge is all about
we're gonna kick you in the flippin
pants don't join this challenge if you
just want a little comfortable tell you
what you want to hear a little friendly
group of people we're here to get you
results man this is the YouTube
influencer challenge we want you to grow
a highly profitable and look high-impact
YouTube channel we're purpose driven
entrepreneurs here at think media we
think that YouTube and social media is
one of the greatest tools for making a
difference in the lives of people and
some of you gonna start business
channels some of you already have a
business you got a product got a service
some of you want to inspire some of you
want to motivate some of you want to
educate there's so much opportunity to
get out messages that matter and so
that's what this thing is all about
number three for audit your circle man
connect with the strong
that's a coffee with candles all about
we're gonna bring on Andrew here in a
second and and then smart strategy and
if you want to get this is this is for a
limited time because we've never done
this before I don't know if we're I will
do it do it again we're gonna be
breaking down and giving you our seven
step proprietary youtube growth system
for free during the youtube influence
challenge those are the five tips click
like if you got value question of the
day how many subscribers do you have
right now and what is your youtube
channel all about tell me in the
comments section below
I lost Andrew so I don't even know where
we're going next but shout me out where
you're watching from and what you've
been doing during this lockdown and I
would love to have you jump on Alena
share the link and if you're over on the
YouTube chat I'll drop you the link as
well
good to see you londa angel tip Tiger
spreadsheet solutions Wendy thanks for
being here man I'm so fired up for this
challenge Heather's gonna be training
we're gonna do some special episodes
with the think media team talking about
tech helping you out Shannon has got
seven subscribers right now Shannon I
believe you can get to a hundred in the
next 30 days for real especially with
some of these strategies
mahai oh hey there from Spain thanks for
being here Oksana from Seattle
Sutherland Center Sean what are you
drinking I am drinking water out of a
mason jar with a tipped edge trying not
to cut my lips hide it this way had a
little bit I didn't really pace out my
coffee yesterday right it was kind of
like I did a lot in the morning and then
a low an and and I've been eating this
sword eatin arrow pressing this
delicious blend from Vesta coffee so
good trying to bring some people on
what's up Bobby a burly one of our VRA
community members right there 66,000 and
growing with our help happy to help me I
appreciate you so much hey if you want
to jump on Bobby and want to chat and
strategize I'm surprised man we got we
got time here for coffee with candle
I got devices not connected in my back
look you got to have like a webcam or
your phone you got to have your audio
and I got to see you and hear you if you
want to jump on Alena drop the link and
so all you got to do is click the stream
yard link that's in the comments it'll
pull you in in the back end link up your
camera link up your audio get your green
audio level to the good level and and
that will bring you on and coffee with
candle is the show where we help you
pivot your plan and you know get results
with YouTube social media and growing
your business right now it's all
connected know the importance of this
season you're in and a wise person you
will be come on let me know we Cassandra
kiss kiss kiss Sarah sorry car issah
Karissa just signed up for the YouTube
influencer challenge whoever's in my
back-end right now man I can't see you
but it looks like Ron's coming on and it
looks like it's gonna work so let's
bring in Ron hey Ron how's it going
what are you watching from and what you
do hey Shawn it's good to meet with you
I'm in Houston and I've been in VR a
since last October awesome and what's
your business or your brand so I've got
two channels one is more faith oriented
I have a podcast called first 15 it's
more of a kind of a Bible devotional the
other is my leadership blog and YouTube
channel where I give advice about
emotional intelligence and goal-setting
and just you know personal achievement
so I've been a leadership coach for
about 20 years Wow awesome and what's
that one called
it's the channel is my own name it's Ron
opens house for your last name it's O
LT M a NS awesome would thanks so much
for jumping on what's going on in
Houston how's this thing affected you
not really bad I mean we've been
sheltering in place for like over a
month now
but working from home isn't a big you
know change for me and we've not had
like you know a lot of you know the sort
of problems that you see in New York and
some of the other big cities so we're
just seeing a lot of people out walking
and kind of you know actually bonding
more with people outside of the safe
distance so I'm trying to find ways to
connect more and use this opportunity
online with people and also just be an
encouragement and to skill up some of
the stuff that you've been talking about
I love it and how can I help what's your
question today so the thing that I'm
looking at is it so I'll just tell you
the my wife is probably my best advocate
and support love her so much she had a
background in TV production in Singapore
where we met and we got married you know
over 20 years ago first couple years for
our life I was married to a TV producer
and then when we moved to the US she
couldn't find a job in TV and went off
and did other things and so she's been
away from it for a long time and she's
been in education lately but she gives
me the best advice about you know my
stuff my content and how to reach more
people and I'll say this the thing that
I've heard is feedback from her and also
the things I see in the market is that I
give a lot of content maybe too much I
in like a 10 minute video my wife says
that's a whole course right there that's
a mini-course and so she's trying to get
me to chop it up into smaller bits and
put it out and so like I just dropped
one on you can see it's self awareness
and I really I think she's right there's
something in that that I have probably
you know too much content even in 10 or
11 minutes and so I've been trying to
put like 30-second blurbs up on Twitter
and LinkedIn and find some traction with
that so I'd like some help on how do I
connect with the audience because I'm
still looking for the audience honestly
yeah yeah well a couple things first and
foremost thanks so much for being on and
grateful you're part of the VRA
community this particular channel is
still really just starting right your
six videos in
two months in and it's one of those
things you know this too in leadership
like don't despise small beginnings and
we really believe it takes and even from
our studies and research 35 to 55 videos
to trigger the algorithm so there's
something about not being overly
judgmental about your results even in
these first early videos you're still
getting your footing you're getting your
traction and your conditioning YouTube
about what your topic is all about in
this case leadership so that's that's
thing one and great job had already
jumping in and creating content thing to
immediately that I would dive down on if
I was you and be starting is there's a
truth that to get a YouTube channel
activated you kind of need a breakout
video it doesn't mean that all of your
videos have to be related to kind of a
breakout video strategy or whatever but
to get a breakout video nobody knows
we're on yet a lot of people are sharing
kind of personal development or
leadership type of topics like this and
so from kind of a picture of you
self-awareness emotional intelligence in
the thumbnail type of title and
thumbnail that's gonna be a hard way to
get discovered one of the best ways to
get discovered is to is to connect to
something people do know and connect
your topic to that so you've got the
YouTube hyper growth blueprint I believe
as a course that's paired with video
ranking Academy and in there we talked
about ten youtube strategies and two of
which one is influencer surfing and one
is trend surfing and they're both very
similar and it's the idea of what has
influence people don't know Ron
but people know shackleton right and
they know which with the famous
leadership book and of course example of
leadership with what happened with
Shackleton up in the Arctic or whatever
it was and how he led his men so there's
maybe somebody looking up for
information on that or even more current
maybe they know even something in terms
now this might seem crazy
but let me ask you this do you use any
software or tools for your own personal
productivity or project management I
have I have dipped my foot into Trello
and I'm trying to use that more but of
course I just use the apps on my
smartphone in my schedule and things
like that Google the whole suite of the
Google Drive so what's your leadership
background like what's contexts have you
let in so I about around 2000 I was
jumping really big into coaching and I
did executive coaching and fortune 500
companies we actually moved our family
over to China in 2011 and we lived in
Shanghai for a couple of years and I
worked with a lot of big multinational
companies there when we moved back to
the States to Houston around 2013-2014
kind of went into a midlife crisis you
know and wasn't really working I mean I
continued having my clients from a
distance but I didn't really focus so
much on building the career and the
business I was I did some faith stuff
and I was working on writing books and
so my background is more like kind of
the traditional corporate coaching but
I've always been working in with small
business people as well and that's
really kind of where my heart is is
helping the entrepreneurs the startups
the the smaller lean enterprises so
that's where it is so so I mentioned ok
maybe you use this an app like Trello of
a video on maybe like how to use Trello
for project management because people
search Trello could get you discovered
on your channel and then people go oh
you're teaching leadership and I connect
with Ron let me subscribe and stay
around for emotional intelligence
emotional literacy and motivation
furthermore when you think about
influencer surfing or trend surfing
maybe it's a company name people don't
know Ron but they know Tesla and I don't
know if we go back to those days but
maybe you worked with a company that
you're like three lessons I learned from
working at or consulting with Accenture
you know or five truths fortune 500
leaders need to know but maybe it's an
actual company company name that could
have influence maybe also is a trend in
entrepreneurship so where people mistake
this trend is they almost try to be or
this strategy is they almost are try to
be gimmicky with it like you don't need
to get weird and be like okay well
YouTube's about gaming so I'm let me try
to like tie into gaming well that's
probably not your thing but if you tie
into business insider articles you tie
into what's actually happening you know
what I mean like in the zeitgeist of
business and trends that are happening
this is just to get your YouTube channel
discovered at some level Shawn Connell
the brand the person on my personal
channel I have something like 90
thousand subs and if I just upload a
video it's kind of a ghost town over
there but it'll probably get a thousand
views no matter what I talk about well
that's because I talked about a lot of
other things that people were looking
for first so that's the big strategy I
would give you is and then of course
dive into your members area and really
go deep in the module on influencer
surfing and trend surfing is that making
sense it is and I hadn't thought about
really tapping into that but I mean like
we did a lot of work with Cisco and I'm
back like 1012 years ago I mean I did
sales master's training if their global
center and Research Triangle Park and
I'm just thinking I met a lot of cool
guys there a lot of interesting things
that they were doing and so you know
talking about kind of an update of you
know what we learned and also where
things are today with this connected
world my wife was telling me just last
night I mean she does all this you know
great stuff she's saying hey did you
know the guys from zoom actually came
out of Cisco WebEx and they were like
you know they've taken the world by
storm I mean if you'd invested in them
in December when they had ten million
users now they're like 200 million users
yes really it's gone crazy so that would
be a trend and I think that's what
you're getting
yeah and add value to think marketing
and think media community
I want you telling stories too so
whenever you connect a video so you
might teach a lesson through a story so
you're you think back so
and you might even tie into that you so
you talk about how some stocks rising
and a lesson you learned and people then
and here's what happens people begin to
see your history your credibility your
authority your experience you unpack one
truth and I think your wife's probably
right I learned it from Andy Stanley he
said a lot of pastors that are preparing
sermons they have four points and their
sermons and they always go away too long
I asked my background so that's why I'm
always landing sometimes and like if you
gotta speed up here so we can get some
other guests on but I'm always going so
long yeah and Andy Stanley said yo you
got four points that's four weeks that's
like one point a week you have a
month-long sermon you don't have to even
like try to come up with with with four
points every single week he's like keep
going down doubling down and then put
more story around things put more
illustrations around things put more of
your history around things and that's
even on YouTube like if you could think
about what are ten leadership lessons
that every new leader should know you
could go I can do a quick video on that
two minutes each it could be a 20 minute
video I'm saying no timeout make it a 10
part series one video one lesson one
story and talk about who you've worked
with talk about Cisco and I think that
connected to jumping on some stuff
that's actually happening in culture
that's really gonna be the key to
getting some traction is that helpful
that's very helpful I really appreciate
it I mean like Corby are a you've got an
hour and a half or so of videos and
training and it's like that's more than
I can implement in a month
and you know you got tons of stuff there
so I think you know we're natural
teachers and so we've got to think about
our learners and where they are on the
front end so I really appreciate this
stuff about trend surfing and connecting
with where people are right now so
thanks so much for that
you're welcome Ron hey appreciate you
and thanks so much for coming on coffee
with Cannell thanks all right take care
hey if you're getting value and remember
this show is also not just about
individual coaching but I think we can
all apply trend surfing influence
surfing and again if you have questions
about any of our products and programs
you can always go to talk
with think.com and something I think
media team would love to jump on the
phone with you
because obviously we're talking about
like our YouTube hyper growth program
and video ranking Academy but look trend
surfing influence surfing and let's
weave in stories in our videos because
you know it's kind of sort of a business
way to say it but facts tell stories
sell facts tell stories so there's
something about like okay facts this
point that point and then story though
we lean in it's both it's like what
point are you trying to make illustrate
it with story make the point again and I
don't know maybe I did that intuitively
earlier but I started telling you about
my background I started telling you
about I am a small town kid and maybe
you started leaning in like oh I can
relate to some of that and it
Illustrated a story of audit your circle
when I got around a community that
leveled me up I started to accelerate
faster story of my background
illustrates the point I don't even know
if I did that well but that kind of can
help hey we got Bobby on the show Bobby
Everly how's it going man good to see
you hey dude it's good to see you too
man thanks a lot hey tell everybody what
you're up to and where you're watching
from well I'm like back to back I'm
Houston guess again but I work from home
I've done politics for 26 years and my
own company since 2007 so I you know I'm
shut-in but I guess I'm always shut-in
so the only thing I can't do now is go
to the gym but otherwise things have
been you know business as usual kind of
normal around here just trying to you
know work with you and others to ramp up
the channel to really peak at the right
time in this election season yeah and
things have been going great right what
are some of the results we did some
coaching a while back and you jumped
into video ranking Academy but what's
been happening on the channel oh dude
it's it's been great I mean the trends
are going in the right direction now and
it's just a smarter approach you know
before I think I got lucky with some
growth I had some built-in reach already
some influence but now it's applying
some real techniques that say hey we're
growing on YouTube because we're doing
good
strategy's not just coming with a bunch
of social media influence or huge email
lists and stuff which I think I took to
a certain level now it's all right let's
do the titles let's use bid iq let's
research and grow from there and it
really I see the the results happening
that's amazing and yeah it's cool to see
also love the hustle and one of the
strategies we talked about was
multiplying your content right so you
already have your daily or three days a
week show right cried a couple clips out
of that so people might say twenty-seven
uploads dear God like you know how could
i but but you also just really tripled
your content in in a sense you tripled
your uploads true yeah and that's the
thing that was so easy I go from three
videos a week to I think for the past
like week and a half there's been a
video every day but it's been no real
work because the show is already post
produced it's there and I just literally
trim it throw it in screen on and it's
it's ready to go and so what they're
getting thousands of views and so it's
like it's no extra work I do the
research like you're teaching as far as
still getting some good intro I mean
descriptions titles things like that to
make those videos still stand out as
much as they can but as far as the
workload that everyone knows as content
creators goes into making the video it's
done man it's it's already it's already
done yeah I love it man I mean congrats
on all the success and respect for the
hustle I love your doubling down right
now you definitely are a wise son right
no like because you're you're not
wasting you're not sleeping through the
day of opportunity and you know that
it's not just season where we're locked
down a lot of news happening and you're
already jumping on that of course based
on your niche but hey it's election year
and so such a time to make an impact and
and so hey how can I help you got a
question well yeah it's just okay so we
do the research right and now we see the
video growing and I might see some some
tags or description words that that
might be making it into sir
right so should I should I kind of chase
the video I mean should I tweak the
title sherry tweak the description based
on how I see that some of the tags or
keywords are doing yes so here's the
thing with tags - there's not there's
not kind of a debate out there because
YouTube admitted that tags really don't
carry that much weight mm-hmm like they
don't have that much influence but
here's the key with tags is they carry
all the weight in the world by doing
your research before you press record we
have a YouTube influencer challenge
where we're actually just gonna be kind
of going through the seven R's of VRA
that's coming up and if people want to
be a part of that that is at the tube
influence comm if you're just joining
make sure that you jump on that and you
know one of those ARS as you know is
research before you press record when
you do that if you are given language in
a keyword in a title and a tag you're
you're actually giving the wording then
what you want that to do potentially
more than anything else is influence
your title your title should be written
for humans it doesn't need to be keyword
stuffed or some robotic sounding thing
but you want that title in there you
want that keyword phrase in there
because titles my friends carry major
weight and I think that's the key so you
might say okay I'm gonna be talking
about this particular political figure
or this particular topic and here's the
title I would have done but then your
research informs you here's how I
actually should title the video
different your opportunity there from
doing your research is what YouTube is
showing you and what Google is showing
you is the language that humans are
using and the chance to rank is there's
more opportunity than ever before but
it's most influenced by the title its
second barely most influenced by the
description and then tags have just a
tiny bit of weight and I should clarify
that it's actually the content itself
and how people interact with that is
that making sense though so so not
getting - if you will hung up on the
tags but when you get insight from the
tags you go okay I'm actually gonna
pivot and title the video a little bit
different than I would have thought mom
and
that small tweak can really lead to
giant Peaks yeah yeah and that's that's
what I'm seeing so I'm gonna spend a
little time doing that and it seems to
be helping and I just wanted to check
man I love it well hey I'm so grateful
you're a part of our community and keep
uploading those videos I love this fact
27 uploads in the last month you want to
get views on YouTube yeah post videos on
YouTube and you are my friend
trust me obviously already seen results
look if this was the only results you
got by the way meaning like you could
just consistently this is amazing like
if your channel grew by 600 subs a month
you know a quarter million views a month
but here's the power with the strategy
that you're doing right now you will
have a breakout video I assure you
in the next three to six months you're
gonna hit a video that's just a banger
it's gonna hit a hundred thousand one
hundred fifty thousand it might hit six
hundred thousand and those watching
remember you're one ranked video away
you're one breakout video away from
changing your life and business the cool
thing is you ought to be committed to
the process so just like Bobby he's
hustling put out the videos the process
is amazing it's not like you're not
getting results in the process if you're
doing things right it's that by staying
disciplined you're positioning yourself
and more uploads are more at-bats you
know it's that it's that right thumbnail
that right title at the right time
around the right topic boom yeah yep
say appreciate you Bobby thanks so much
for coming on the show yeah thanks a lot
we'll see it hey coffee with Cannell we
are crushing it on a Tuesday got the
club going up on a Tuesday what are we
talking about alright we're gonna have
Xena on here in a second but if you beg
in value out of these coffee with
candles hit the like button question of
the day how many subscribers do you have
and what is your YouTube channel all
about let me know in the comments
section wherever you're watching maybe
you know somebody that wants to pivot
their plan right now needs to double
down on YouTube share this maybe tag
somebody let them know about the show
here to help you go further faster and
give you strategies that work and not do
if you're just joining we started with
five
tips for getting your first 100
subscribers or your first hundred
thousand and we're also going deep with
Q&A as well and so I'm excited
we have Xena in the house Xena what is
up hello how's it going it's going good
how are you doing great thank you
hey tell me where you're watching from
what your business is or brand and
what's happening during this lockdown
for you so curly in Michigan I'm in my
mom's basement I think I want to be a
motivational speaker like I've been
through so many things don't know
exactly like my niche but I'm all about
positivity inspiring people but I
haven't like locked down the exact like
target audience
all right what's a guy see your channel
hey you got you got a hundred subs you
got 2160 right no I
21:50 I believe let me see here trying
to share this this is you right that
isn't yes Russian good job and I don't
know what this all about
have you I know yes I uh I stopped
posting like in October hey why did you
stop I was going through a lot of things
and like I moved out of my parents house
then I came back and potentially might
be relocating to Houston so how were you
if you don't mind me asking I'm 29 years
old and I think of the age yeah yeah ya
know you're super young and um and so
what's your question specifically how
can I help
question is how do I I know it's
consistency's patient I feel like I'm
really good with like making vlogs and
putting I mean I've been doing it for
years where I can post on all platforms
but there's no growth it's like I'm
missing some kind of puzzle piece I've
been watching you for a few years now so
thank you for being amazing okay well
yeah let me share a couple things I
think first of all sometimes we just got
a reframe I mean no growth is not true
when you were posting you're getting 325
views of video 187 views of video now I
know we live in this crazy world where
we see youtubers getting millions of
views but like that's insane you've got
you've got your channel trailers got
five thousand eight hundred views like
if you would have told my grandparents
that you know that five thousand eight
hundred humans that they didn't know
would have viewed their home video that
they uploaded into the sky of
electricity now shared through different
phones you know they would have thought
you were crazy and they would have
thought it was insane because they were
only known by their 50 neighbors right
so I think there's just something about
a reframe I definitely am empathetic to
hit in a season where you get
discouraged and and maybe stop posting
but sometimes it's just I think about
acknowledging that man if you're being
viewed by like a hundred people you're
being viewed by like 300 people or form
of people got a lot of people watching
and and being even at in a state of
gratitude and patience reverence for
that of course we all want more and we
also want to be sustainable and to
really make a living as a content
creator there does need to be like a
tipping point depending on your
monetizing strategies there's something
about just being so grateful with what
you have and stewarding that and being
willing to serve those people for one
year five years because you really never
know when the breakthroughs gonna come
that's kind of just a prospective
foundation but the next thought I would
think is I mean what do you need to do
right now as far as making money live in
life like you got it like are you trying
to make money from this do you want to
make money online like what's the what
is your goal there yeah I want to have
my own brand and it's all about like I
tell people my my life is represented by
a train
slow and steady but I get through
everything I want that to be my icon
that represents me but I work for a
company but I don't want that to be my
how do you do for the company I am a
logistic planner and I might be getting
promoted to a supervisor but that's just
my security like I went to school got a
degree you love social media no I do you
love social media yes I love putting a
smile on people's faces and you said you
also post across all platforms and you
and so like you're used to creating
content for all platforms yeah like I
started off doing Fitness because I lost
60 pounds but it not discouraged because
I didn't grow the way I expected it to
but that's because I stopped yeah
so that's on me but then I was like let
me be him I want to spread the
positivity cause like I was I was
depressed and unhappy in life and when
you break through and you find that
positive light it just changes your
whole perspective so I want to help
people find their happiness and I love
it so you know a couple thoughts like
there's a by the way you know there's
there's so many great people out there
there's different people in terms of
that they give advice and I think
there's a proverb that says there's
wisdom in a multitude of counselors and
then you you kind of figure out a path
and you got to figure out the path
that's right for you I think marketing
and I think media we really lean in the
practical path and I think that one of
the hard things to do is there's a lot
of people who kind of just want to
inspire vlog and be fun and kind of have
fun or or rather even just make others
happy like it's kind of it's a kind of a
trend you know building a brand if you
will that is sort of just on that
inspiring type of positioning therefore
we usually teach that it's really good
to figure out your specific thing which
might be your way of getting known and
discovered especially as related to
things that are search based maybe it's
related to a skill you have you know
that's why channels that are in an
I really believe had an advantage when
you double down on gardening or you
double down on teaching a certain kind
of software or you double down on career
planning and career tips like our friend
Kass who is just on the think marketing
podcast or or something specific you
know here's the reality let me just
illustrate with my own kind of life I
like you want to inspire one of my
biggest passions is personal development
leadership and I like to motivate I like
to speak same thing I like in a way I
would argue I'm kind of a motivational
speaker but yet the reason you probably
even know me and the reason you're even
on coffee with Cannell is because I
found one specific skill that I have and
that was video and my background in
cameras and I started to build a channel
around that what's crazy is now that
think media is at a million subscribers
I pretty much have built a Death Star
Star Wars reference come on May 4th
yesterday and that can destroy planets
that can shoot a laser beam at other
projects that I want to do and a portion
of that audience might want to go watch
it which is what people need on YouTube
so I essentially could in a way do it I
essentially could go start my speaking
and I really already have right and my
motivation career but because I built
something really practical is that
making sense in a niche that's really
practical if you had to pick something
what are like one two three niche
YouTube channels that come to mind that
it could be based on your skills or
hobbies or background channels like
other people's channels yeah like I mean
are you into gaming gardening any kind
of software and one of them for me was
content creation for you because if
you've created a lot of content
obviously you have your day job you have
your degree and that's kind of your
security but I'm wondering like one of
the things you could really do is you've
pumped out a bunch of YouTube videos
you've built a channel to 2160
subscribers or whatever it is which is
nuts because there's
everyone in the world right now is
trying to start YouTube everyone
lockdown every kind of church leader
business cupcake maker dog trainer and
they also don't know how to do it they
don't want to do it you know how to film
you know how to edit you know how to
post you know how to do thumbnail you
know how to do all of the things and so
another path or all tied together you
potentially could go intern work for it
get hired by someone and in a way growth
hack your brand in the process of
helping somebody else build theirs by
doing what you love social media and
creating content on all platforms that
make sense yeah this I mean I've thought
of that idea as well yeah and you have
to jump cut I can tell immediately you
got to drop any edits your understanding
the time in timing you know how to pop
buttons up and whatnot and and you could
have one two three four local clients
helping them do all these skills that
you love doing that you've already built
up now that's that's that's could do
like your day job or whatever but I'm
thinking what what searchable hobbies or
passions do you have like I love videos
about that people are like looking for
on YouTube that's not just a general
vlog or that's not just a hot like
that's not just a you know I was
thinking doing modified work us I know a
lot of people do the workouts but they
don't really like going to depth of how
to modify three four different ways for
one workout what kind of workouts did
you do I do strength training and a lot
of cardio but it's I would say cardio
quick probably like turbo fire chalene
johnson yeah yeah okay so and then and
by the way that's a phenomenal niche
crowded yes as is everything but it's
people are looking for it one of the
opportunities in there then is also the
niche down to the who you're targeting
the type of you know because people
people that need modify
modifiers are different than people of
different body types as you know people
have different fitness levels as you
know and so like for example we've got a
woman a woman in our community that does
fashion tips for women over 40 really
good niche down not trying to reach the
whole internet fashion tips for women
not just women but for even a specific
age group I think there's something
about Millennials maybe that's
interesting
because immediately you are separating
from for for who you're trying to reach
and so you know I don't know if you jump
back in on your current channel you
certainly could I think you could take
it any direction you want I do think
there's something about staying
committed to something as you said and
and I want to actually just challenge
you as well I know you've been through
some hard seasons but you
self-admittedly defined your own brand
for me that you're like a train you're
slow and steady and I think there's
something about committing to this again
and being content and not even saying
that people would kill for the 829 views
that you got eight months ago so like
you already have like people who loved
your content they're watching you
they're vibing with you I mean again
it's all perspective it's like again we
look up here we go oh man PewDiePie it's
got 100 million subs and then we go
I'd only got a hundred twenty-nine views
829 views you freaking kidding me that's
freaking insane
and so but if it's that that's that is
um look and let's look some stuff up
here as we land a plane modified
strength training when I think about
obviously a lot of huge channels and
things to compete with but when I see
specific videos that have 1 million
views even this video like you could
make this it's two years old it's the
top ranking video types of training
methods what is resistance strength
training for beginners 50,000 subscriber
channel and 34,000 views on this this
video here's my point
if you commit to something like this and
you do it and you build it and you post
a
videos and you get better at even
posting the right videos and just like
talking to Bobby you have a breakout
video people get to know you in the
process and guess what they get to see
in the process they get to see that wow
Zenna is super motivating she is
inspirational wow I am happier because
of following her wow I'm more healthy
because of following her so you kind of
told me your mission but you're
connecting your mission to a practical
path and I'm telling you this you start
getting a youtube channel at 10,000 subs
15,000 25,000 and you are also building
your brand and you're working on your
personal branding in the process and
growing as a speaker then then your
speaking then you start getting speaking
invites and your speaking at you have a
lot of different opportunities
opportunities to speak at our conference
growth video live opportunities to speak
in the YouTube world the marketing world
because you're building on YouTube but
then opportunities to say oh yeah Xena
is she's a strength trainer she's got
this sick youtube channel and she's been
inspiring a lot of people but she's
probably been inspiring women whatever
your niche shall be in each town and
she's kind of built up this group of the
trainers they're people they're like
trains whatever they do they get through
slow and steady and she's built up this
movement of a couple thousand women like
again there's not to be a million like
just some this is like in a way micro
movement and there's so many ways to
then monetize by serving people at a
super high level and then niching down
like that
and so is that making sense
yeah it's helping a lot cool any final
questions on that you got it then you're
the bomb and thanks so much for coming
on to the show I really appreciate you
appreciate it thank you hey coffee with
Cannell I hope you got some value out of
that last one any insights for you who
are you trying to reach or what problem
do you solve for them let me know in the
comments section by the way if you want
to start a vlog channel you want to vlog
you want to inspire and kind of make
if you will kind of follow my life and
get to know me personally and what not a
lot of people are doing that on YouTube
very few break through and succeed
percentage ly it's not that you can't do
it I think there's just something about
counting the cost you know my favourite
leader of all time is Jesus Christ right
and obviously my faith as well but even
just from a practical standpoint know
what's your background or your belief is
you study the historical figure and you
talk about deep wisdom I'm crying I mean
started the biggest movement that's
still going today with over two billion
people in the movement Christianity and
then you even the long tail anyways I
digress he said count the cost to
building the tower so you don't stop
start building and then find out that
you ran out of money halfway through
really wise so there's something about
starting with the end in mind there's
something about having a strategy
there's something about thinking things
through and then following through
that's why we have a strategy in a
process that we go through
and so just started with the end in mind
and thinking okay sometimes maybe you
can still get to the same path and I
believe Xena can actually get to the
same path she wants but maybe the
vehicle that gets her there looks a
little bit different than you thought
and not that I don't want to have the
hubris to think that again I could just
do whatever I want and it would be
successful but there's something about
building a youtube channel getting known
building an email list building a social
media following provided you're still
aligned in your niche and you're adding
some value you could say like I don't
know like maybe I want to start a
supplement line today maybe you'd be
interested because you follow me on
Instagram stories and you know that I'm
into high-performance and I could
probably sell more than the person with
zero followers maybe I want to start a
new podcast that is about motivation and
inspiration you're like I would be into
that and so you thought there's that
make sense and the reason though is
because you're here for think marketing
or think media or I hope you find a
camera that's a practical way that we
got connected but then people get to
know you they get to know what your
beliefs are your values are your vision
is and some people resonate because your
vibe attracts your tribe so that's what
I want to know who what problem do you
solve and who
are you trying to reach who do you serve
and what problem do you solve there's
two really important questions who and
what who and what who and what who do
you help I help people build their
influence with online video what problem
do you solve cameras strategies lighting
software tactics growth who and what who
and what Sean do you help bloggers now I
can't write very good out spell I get
main who and what who and what Sean do
you help people with Final Fantasy seven
now but I watch the video so I'm trying
to get those tactics about how to crush
it through Midgar man come on we're
gonna take down Shinra you know who and
what who and what do you help people
cook now I'm not that good I like to eat
I could help people eat maybe I should
start a mukbang channel but but I can't
cook who and what so you you double down
on a particular skill and man it opens
up your whole future and your world to
you now we got I fun Chris on wait where
are you watching from California
man you guys are locked down people are
upset about the beaches being closed oh
yeah
bummer man tell me about what your
YouTube channel is all about and how I
can help
so for a while and 878 yes my man Oh
what your na that's a small town yeah
yeah do I see some games behind you man
what game are you playing right now my
man yes hey what question do you have
that I could help with so I'm back with
my flaws oh you're just stuck at 78 yes
all right let's look so you're a comedy
on YouTube yeah whoops okay and and
you've been let's see here five so one
video a week roughly yes now I don't I
mean obviously we want to go faster but
bro you got four new subscribers in the
last month oh yeah that's I mean that's
that's cause you got 310 views to I want
to go faster too but like just something
to to really sit back and appreciate
that's that's not zero it's not going
backwards you're going forward so that's
really cool Wow okay a couple things I
went to your most popular videos here
and I'm looking at the most popular one
why do you think this one did so good
okay well it's from it's only about a
year old so exactly one year old and
this is you doing pies in the face
compilation yeah yeah well my man here's
my tip for you
success leaves clues so man people love
these pie videos these are like your
best videos yeah yeah so I would
encourage you to to maybe do more pie
videos I mean that's if it's about
getting views and growth there's
something about I think looking at your
top videos and thinking about how to
double down on those and then I also
think about I think that this style of
kind of you're just using what you have
what do you film this on yeah which is
awesome so you're just getting started I
think if you I don't think the
production value actually matters a ton
but I do like like even this this got
182 views which is super rad All Things
Considered but you know it's shot
vertical we got almost black over here
wasn't shot super good it's kind of
pixelated so again two tips number one
look at some of your best performing
videos and think about how you can
double down on those and then I love
your hustle man at least one video a
week so then keep posting try to get one
percent better with every upload so what
that makes me think is if there was
better like a little bit of better
lighting I again I don't think this
content needs but it's it's so low
resolution better lighting I think
there's something about then
experimenting and kind of trying
different things with your content like
slow motion what kind of phone you got
yeah I think it probably does like 120
frames slow motion so you go into your
video mode maybe you know experiment
with some slow motion experiment with
sound effects music levelling up your
content right you know so you start
doing this in different ways and bro in
comedy you could get a breakout video
you could get a viral video maybe it's
like pie in the face but it's like you
know the way it's edited the way that it
happens the creativity of it it makes me
think of like slow-mo guys have you
heard that channel before oh wow so look
that channel up and that's going to and
then I want to challenge you
I love the success or the hustle of
posting try to percent better with every
upload because slow-mo guys let's
actually look at them just really quick
this would probably take you a long time
to shoot edit and and build out
something like this but slow-mo glitter
obviously they're shooting with some
crazy what do you call it like phantom
cameras like a thousand frames per
second but I think you could do some
interesting things there's a like red
camera or whatever they're using and
they're doing kind of so I think that
imagine if you did a slow-mo potentially
like Pi compilation you do it creatively
get outside get in the Sun you do some
different things and it might be your
breakout video now I'm sure you love
doing this as a hobby you love doing it
for fun but you probably want to make
some money too right
yes yeah for sure
it'd be a while and and you know like I
like based on your ambitions or whatever
you know again if you get a hundred
thousand user a million subscribers on a
video or something you could get I mean
a million views if you were to get a
million views let's assume they're CPM
is like three bucks or something you
don't know how to give use oh whoa oh
yeah yeah yeah I'm just saying that if
you get a million views you could make
like three thousand dollars off of if it
was like a three dollar CPM so I'm
saying if like one of your videos
obviously it's a huge channel huge
production value but I'm telling you
this as a final point is double down on
your topics and experiment more with
that your best performing content level
up your content maybe put more into the
video production value wise even just
with your phone you can add it on your
phone shoot on your phone we got a
little slow motion got some music got
some creative editing in there and that
right video hits at the right time you
know gets a hundred thousand views you
might make 150 bucks you're having fun
process because you love doing this and
and then you just keep loving leveling
up and doubling down and seeing kind of
what people are asking for in terms of
comedy and paying attention to your
community into the comments that helpful
bro yeah my man I appreciate you thanks
thanks so much for supporting the book
did you read it
awesome man well keep crushing the book
thanks so much for coming on with coffee
with Cannell I appreciate you and great
job on getting at least one video out a
week a lot of people aren't pressing
record and so I'm inspired that you are
thank you
you got it Chris thanks for coming on
what cheers bro yeah all right hey
coffee with Cannell we've got a couple
more coming on in a second here and then
I'm going into meeting
today um so fired up hey this episode of
the coffee with Cannell show is brought
to you by tube influence comm if you
haven't heard we are doing a challenge
what's the challenge a challenge is a
seven-day live every single day learn
how to start and grow a high impact and
high profit YouTube channel in 2020 if
you're a creator or business owner
influencer or an entrepreneur we want to
invite you to participate in this free
challenge if you haven't started your
YouTube channel yet you want to be there
how to start it right get views best
ways to make money even if you don't
have a product or a business how to
create irresistible videos and that gets
your audience to click and keep them
watching the the easiest video creation
process and best cameras for quickly
making videos we're doing so much stuff
on this challenge and so if you go here
join then you can get in I can't wait
we're gonna do some bonus live streams
inside of the Facebook group and whatnot
tube influence com starting May 12th and
link in the description below or in the
facebook comments this is the channel
show I should say that we help you with
your business your brand level up on
social media right now and so we got I
see Mike coming on I see Mike mom a man
how you doing it's good to see you good
to see look at this is terrible
look at this thing oh man I know that
happens to some of those ear cups
yeah the old hag bet but they they
probably still sound awesome and feel
great I'm sure yeah yeah they're they're
cured to my head hey tell everybody what
who you are where you're watching from
and I don't know so my name is Mike my
youtube channel is hard to hurt I've
been following Sean since I started on
YouTube I'm in Myrtle Beach South
Carolina we do self-defense and fitness
content on my channel and it's got
170,000 subs and I attribute all of my
especially my early growth now my
Instagram sucks Sean go you got to go to
YouTube this was I just wanted to bring
up this fight that I watched though man
I was watching you
I watched this whole thing now so I was
so pumped well no what happened in here
there's like a backyard just it's an
underground Fight Club called Street
beefs oh my gosh that's a real thing
that really happens in real life you
know I want to like vicariously live
through this is this is this is Fight
Club like but nobody talks about Fight
Club we should have been streaming this
on the internet Fight Club doesn't exist
dude they've got a million subscribers
dang
it's cool I went there actually that was
one of my my three-pronged attack yeah
of blowing up on YouTube was going and
doing like crazy stuff like this nice I
got you okay that's that makes sense
like just hacking you knew like kind of
yeah I love it okay and your YouTube
channel hard to hurt yeah good I'm gonna
help what's going on well I'd real quick
if you don't mind I would like to chime
in and the people that you've been
talking to that want to like expand
their they want to do like general stuff
and they want to do motivational
speaking and cogent stuff like that and
your advice has been you know we'll
niche down and establish some
credibility when we did this we did this
wit video where I got I got whipped with
this thing and that video ended up doing
two million views and now my channel has
170 thousand subscribers and now guys
asks me they ask me like how to meet
girls and they ask me like what they
should do with with where's they should
take their kids to learn martial arts so
like your advice it was like dead-on
like I did something sort of specific
and kind of dumb actually and now people
people want to know what I think about
you know what kind of car they should
get and you know all this stuff that
honestly I never established any
authority on but they follow me but it
established you as a badass man I guess
got win and and in people were like dude
I think the ladies I had the kind of
toughness that you have I'd write crazy
and yeah you got 2.3 million views
testing a stinger tactical whip which
I'm sure people were looking for and
then it wasn't even the fact that like
probably some people were just put
this thing against like whatever you
know yeah water bottles and whatnot they
do they actually whip you on it is that
eventually what happens yes that not
right go back just a little bit before
there yeah okay yeah all right here we
go
oh he's hitting yeah what is this a good
one coming up here yes
the bad one this is us we we actually
went back three days later I realized I
didn't take a hard enough shot so he had
to take a hard shot there might be some
language I know that you're the
family-friendly Channel yeah turn this
down yeah might be some language cool he
gets me in the armpit here but this this
was a joke this we didn't take this
video seriously at all sure and it ended
up as you would say crushing it here we
go this one okay turn turn it up and
then turn it down at impact
after 15% is like nominee yeah we doing
this all week all right all right all
right oh man I love it yeah yeah I'll
let you even go deeper on that but but
though people are looking for the
tactical stinger man plus they probably
think you know spoiler it hurts they
wanted to see the thing and they want to
see that yeah and that ended up opening
doors for me and not just from like
personal fulfillment like now I get I'm
connected with more people now yeah like
logistically like the we didn't have an
affiliate link for that when with that
video came out but when that dude
started selling out of him he hit me up
and was like yo can we do some affiliate
marketing that thing killed it that
thing paid several months of my mortgage
that video all by itself and you hear
that think marketing come on that video
paid several months of my mortgage but
it's in a niche yes right for that you
paid the price for that video too
yeah um the affiliate marketing crush
that ad revenue from it crushed and then
we ended up doing you know follow-up
videos because it was doing so well
but um the the thing that I'm dealing
with now they actually want your help on
yep um my channel my views are actually
steady but my views on my current videos
are much lower which tells me that like
more people are watching my channel
because more people are watching YouTube
right now but I'm not hitting on my
newer stuff as hard I kind of can
predict that when I've been doing this
long enough now when I put a video out I
kind of know what its gonna do like I do
my my maintenance content where this is
a video that I need to put out because
it's a question I get or it's something
I think will help people and then I have
my content that I put out that I know
like this one's gonna go yeah with
things being you know the buzzwords
uncertain I'm having a hard time
balancing putting out content that I'm
like I'm passionate and I really want to
put it out and I that's what I want to
do versus the stuff that I know that
will that will go also my studio being
closed and none of my clients and
students being around to do this stuff
with that makes it kind of tough to but
I'm having a hard time because this is
this is my only income now you choose my
only income
I own a personal training studio we've
still got the bills there but YouTube
has kept us afloat during this time
because you've been locked down to so
has that been shut down yes yeah so all
that overhead is just piled on and you
know like we carried the bills but also
what a illustration of the fact that
your diversity on YouTube is carrying
your brick-and-mortar business during
this time
yeah I'm looking at like my my peers in
this area that did that don't do what I
do and I'm like ow I can't I don't know
what they would be doing right now
because YouTube is literally the only
reason that yep that I'm able to even
pay the bills so I I'm super I'm worried
about all those like gym owners and
studio owners justify because I don't
know what I can't imagine what I would
do course okay a couple things first you
know year-over-year YouTube goes through
changes competition increases sheer
volume of
increase increases across niches and
that's why it's good you build up a base
of subscribers and whatnot but I think
you know judging your present views
there is things you can control and I
know you're a leader so you take maximum
responsibility and you would never you
never be an excuse maker or just like oh
I'm just a victim of the algorithm no no
I think there's something about like
we've seen all kinds of seasons that
think media and we just keep doing what
you're doing
meaning we've seen seasons where it's
like wow there seems to be like wind in
our sails from YouTube and then there's
seasons where it feels like there's no
freaking wind at all and we are row
rowing and sweating and and course we're
rowing upstream we're not getting much
traction some of that's just the reality
of of more competition and whatnot so
what I mean is you just keep doing what
you're doing and you keep posting and
keep posting smart keep uploading videos
and even if the numbers go down more you
look at the net average of you got 1.5
million views a month you've got a lot
of momentum of course there's past
videos doing that I would always ask the
question if I'm you how can I increase
my uploads we just hit 29 uploads in
April you know I got a team helping but
if you double your your videos you can
double your views if you're if your new
video only gets 3,000 views a video but
you double them then they'll all get
3,000 views a video but 26 quote-unquote
out at-bats gives you a chance of
getting some of those past breakouts not
by reducing quality but does that make
sense
yes and that's that was the second part
of my question over the past month
I've added one or two a week I either
I'm doing a livestream of a workout or
I'm doing actually I came I came here to
steal ideas from you to Sean I'm doing a
live call-in podcast where people can
call in and be streamed to audio haven't
done video yet came here to see how that
worked because I like stealing ideas
from you but um the I've upped the UPS
the
upload schedule but I like worry and
help me with this I worry if I'm putting
out stuff that's like a little different
or it's not it's not us at the studio
hitting the bags or lifting weights and
you know like alienating core
subscribers who I've always been very
consistent I upload the same two days
every week I upload the same two types
or three types of content every week and
I'd worry about like long-term I'm just
trying to balance those two things I'm
struggling with that yeah a couple
thoughts on that number one test an
experiment always so like you know
always do it you can always try
something I think it's you have a very
clear brand it's still on brand if you
don't have 20 percent of your budget 20
percent of your inventory 20% of your
time devoted to innovation you're
probably guaranteed to be out of
business in the next two to three years
no matter what industry right you always
have to have 20% yes that what I mean is
if 80% of your time is on the tried and
true content that works you got to have
this 20% bucket where I got even know if
you with Cannell it was it was an
accident it was holy crap were locked
down Heather's like start a show when I
wanna that's insane because the podcast
that I did before I even knew you did
this yeah I was doing a podcast the
software that we use crashed and I lost
the podcast so I figured out how to
stream it to youtube and OBS just to
have a way to save it and then I was
like wait can I capture and then stream
that and it was like just like that it
was accident yeah and so that's that was
innovation experimentation outside of
what we normally do now what we're also
finding out is that we take one segment
of coffee with Cannell per week and we
upload it on think media brand-new
wasn't planning that either this was the
last one this got 13,000 views man is
that Arizona most viewed video last week
on think media was one of the segments
from coffee with Cannell by the way I'm
a production value nerd this is 720p
streaming over stream yard and I was
super frustrated I I was overly romantic
about production value and editing and
so I was like I don't even know if I
would even we're streaming on YouTube
right now
720p man people are gonna judge it there
nah man I haven't seen any complaints
not only that we cut out in a thing and
I thought oh if it doesn't have lower
thirds or little tips and doesn't have
this or that and I made up all this BS
in my head
meanwhile the show is going great people
are loving it you and me are talking we
haven't got to connect like this ever
before
only on Instagram be honest it's good to
hear you say that because just my my
third most recent video is I uploaded a
clip with two guests from the podcast
and it drove me nuts and I was like that
my webcam sucks compared to what I shoot
on and I didn't edit it I caught myself
trying to edit it too much and I was
spending like hours sifting through two
hours of a podcast and I was like just
just upload it just see what it does
dude we got we dropped this one this one
did great here's the point you know from
a past coffee with candle got 13,000
views over on thick media and these are
just going you know straight up they go
straight through and then card on the
end that kills you that like it doesn't
have music or transitions or like all
the stuff man but like it's the values
there and and by the way I don't like
it's it's working now will it's keep
working if it stops will stop we
evaluate well test 20% for those that's
what I need I needed someone to help me
no big just give me something like a
guideline 20% of innovation so you want
to stick with like whether it's search
based the stuff your audience but then
here's the other thing is when you
livestream you lose subscribers it's
like it's I don't know if you ever
noticed that it's always like minus 17
you're like Frick what the heck am i
doing I'm check I'm sure sometimes when
you upload a video you lose subscribers
yeah I don't think I think that you want
to look at a couple things number one
you want to look at net and not
necessarily yeah I try to look at like
90 days at a time I try not exactly
because because you got 15,000 new
subscribers in the last 30 days but one
video might lose 27 look that's people
self-select a man maybe they just have
been like oh hey and I've been meaning
to unsubscribe and now he's uploading so
much I reminded me to you know I only
watched that whip video but I haven't
been painted right that's that's what I
you know they came for the blank
in YouTube you you gotta just hustle you
got a grind you got a post post post
post post according to your brand stay
on the main promise experiment 20% and
your audience will self filter we got to
let people select stuff man people
invest production companies invest you
know ten million dollars in making a
Netflix show and my wife and I get bored
with it in 20 minutes and we say F that
show you know what I mean that we this
likes table what like and people are
gonna be fickle they're gonna choose
what they want to do they're gonna do
what they want to do but net-net you're
getting fifteen thousand new subs my
point is I think now is the time for
creators to create it's to start new
shows and if if your subscribers are so
fickle that they're like he uploads
these to workout videos on Tuesday and
Thursday but then he interrupts my
subscription feed with a podcast callin
show on Saturday and I'm so offended
that I'm gonna unsee yeah let him go I
do you're adding all this value they
don't have to watch every show they can
just also potentially get value out of a
couple episodes you know that they watch
during the week and then I'll watch the
week and stuff so I actually think more
uploads is where you have more
opportunity and that's what I like to
think if mountains gets deeper we get
fitter and so we're uploading more on
think media and we hit four million
views last month we are uploaded twenty
nine videos and yes some of the videos
got 5,000 views do we got a million
subscribers man what's that about what's
the super niche topic about a super
niche camera about how to zoom in on
iMovie but it's also the longtail play
of putting out a couple search based
things that's why our snowball of
momentum is insane because we put out a
lot of like kind of obscure videos
that's the problem of putting on an
iMovie tutorial people are like I don't
use iMovie so they skip over and I'm
like I'm sorry subscribers just let it
get past you because once it gets into
the algorithm that video is gonna serve
people who want that right there might
be years to come there might be ten
dudes who do use iMovie and those ten
dudes might go on to buy a bunch of
stuff on your affiliate marketing and
follow your other you know some of that
stuff your right is not measurable but I
think I think what it was good to hear
from you I think like two months ago I
wouldn't
I'll make what I want I'm gonna upload
whatever I want you know I'll upload ten
minutes of me singing you know but I
think it's just because of the
uncertainty but it you know I've
actually modeled my channel grew within
my niche my channel grew faster than any
of them martial arts channel martial
arts YouTube is low CPM very toxic it's
very a very negative type thing I
watched how you did gear and tech
reviews and I did my martial arts gear
reviews similarly and the affiliate
marketing took off and that affiliate
marketing makes it a little easier to
ignore some of the haters and stuff but
ya know how much you make how much you
make a month on affiliate marketing so
um the whip usually does four or five
hundred yeah it did a it did like twelve
hundred the first month um Amazon is
usually four to five hundred this month
it was twelve hundred nice various other
ones some of the companies I work with
there's probably three or four others
that are between a hundred and two
hundred a month that sort of thing so
kinda like 1500 a couple grand a month
coming in yes it's about it ends up
being probably about thirty or forty
percent of my total YouTube related
income after like Adsense and merch and
stuff like that yeah hey but I watched
how you did gear reviews how you did it
like kind of honestly and sincerely you
said hey there's a link down there if
you wanna check it out but you never
were like this thing is great I love it
you know you must get one and I've
always done it that way and because of
that affiliate marketing has always been
good to me Mike I appreciate you bro hey
no I don't know I appreciate you bro
what you've done for me has kept my
family and business afloat this month
man well that's that's awesome to hear
I'm glad that hey I love that she got
diversity I think that's inspiring for
our community even if they're really
crushed right now you know we're gonna
get through this this too shall pass but
there's gonna be another thing and
that's why this is the season to be
diversifying your income building your
influence building something that gives
you online ability to work from home
work when you can't get customers coming
in or whatever it is and so it's awesome
to see everything you've been doing in
the hospital you're putting in you get
some value out of these tips yeah you
made me feel a lot better
cool man well hey I trust you so you
made me feel better when you said that
awesome well love what you're doing keep
hustling keep us posted with your
results and thanks so much for coming on
the show Thank You Sean all right take
care hey thanks so much for watching
coffee with Cannell if you're not
registered for the YouTube influence
seven-day challenge we're gonna get
crazy seven days in a row actually we
take sunday off and so it actually ends
up being like eight days but you get it
and we start on a Tuesday May 12th we
are training every single day we're
gonna be droppin our proprietary seven
step youtube growth process we've never
shared this publicly before this will
help you get views why you snooze 24/7
even while you sleep and you can see all
the details a tube influence calm link
in the description down below this is
gonna be one of the coolest funnest most
awesomest bad English but really fun
event and look this is YouTube's
stimulus like we're here to help we want
to offer a ton of value we know there's
a lot happening in the world right now
we need each other we need community we
got to skill up this is a season of
opportunity it's time to go all in
content consumptions up does that mean
that it's gonna be easy and there's no
competition never said that it's not
gonna be easy but it's gonna be worth it
especially when you have the right
strategies tips and so join us for the
YouTube challenge thanks for being here
with coffee with can I'll hit the like
button hey thanks for everybody being so
patient and waiting in the back room I'm
five minutes late for my all team
meeting that I'm leaving right now so I
got a jump but hey we'll be back for our
weekly coffee with Cannell show next
week stay tuned on Twitter and on our
email list for updates about that and if
you could be a part of the challenge
it's gonna get crazy that starts next
week as well and every single day we'll
be going live answering questions and
doing a lot of cool stuff and so that's
a tube influence comm appreciate you so
much keep crushing it keep smashing it
check the replay out for five tips on
how to get your first 100 subscribers on
YouTube and I will see you in the next
video
peace